how did a video game ruin the ending of
serenity if you've come for some of the
worst twists in movie history stick
around because you're in the right place
batman begins got people to take the
caped crusader seriously at the movies
again and the dark knight was an
award-winning sensation that's why hype
was understandably huge for the dark
knight rises the final film in
christopher nolan's epic batman trilogy
unfortunately the third film was in many
ways a step down from its predecessors
there are several distracting plot holes
such as bruce wayne's inexplicable
escape to gotham after being imprisoned
on the other side of the planet though
his excessive wealth could be enough
explanation there's a lot to love about
the dark knight rises it's a bombastic
thriller filled with excellent visuals
and great performances especially from
tom hardy's bane the twists weren't
great though the reveal that joseph
gordon-levitt's character's name is
robin made some people roll their eyes
but it ultimately didn't affect the plot
however when miranda tate stabs batman
and reveals herself to be raza ghoul's
daughter talia who has bane on a leash
and is carrying on the legacy of the
league of shadows it was a little harder
to ignore upon the film's release some
fans complained that the twist was too
predictable while others argued that it
undermined bane's abilities as a super
villain regardless of reasoning it's
generally agreed that the ending of the
dark knight rises didn't exactly live up
to the expectations set by its
predecessors
m night shyamalan is a name synonymous
with twist endings shyamalan has had one
of the most bizarre and noteworthy
careers in hollywood history the sixth
sense unbreakable and signs were all
wildly popular establishing him as one
of the hottest directors around at the
start of the millennium a decade later
however most of the moviegoing public's
goodwill towards him had evaporated
thanks to critical duds like the
happening the last airbender and after
earth what happened between the
unforgettable reveal of the sixth sense
and the cringe-inducing cheese of the
last airbender is anyone's guess we do
know where the first signs of trouble
started popping up though 2004's the
village released two years after signs
the village follows a group of 19th
century pennsylvanian townsfolk who are
stalked by strange monsters that lurk in
the woods audiences couldn't wait to see
what neck snapping twist shyamalan had
in store but when it was revealed that
the film actually takes place in the
present day and that the monsters were
just the town elders in costumes most
people weren't impressed still shyamalan
refuses to let bad reviews stop him from
writing crazy twists his most recent
project 2021's old features a similarly
baffling reveal of its own jk rowling
isn't the only one making things worse
for the legacy of the harry potter
franchise the other folks behind the
fantastic beasts movie are helping out
too the first movie in the spin-off
series in which british wizard newt
scamander tries to recapture his escaped
magical creatures in new york city
definitely has its moments redmayne
charms in the lead role his sidekicks
are a blast and the various fantastic
beasts certainly live up to the film's
title however the movie was never really
about capturing billy wigs and
bowtruckles scamander and his friends
have to get to the bottom of an
anti-muggle plot orchestrated by
percival graves the director of magical
security when graves is apprehended his
true identity is revealed he's actually
the legendary dark wizard grindelwald in
disguise that kind of twist might have
worked in a lesser franchise but the
reveal cheapened grindelwald as a
character moving forward worse still it
set up a decidedly unmagical letdown of
a sequel in fantastic beasts the crimes
of brindlewald
it's no surprise that a film about
criminal magicians who rob the rich and
give to the poor is going to have a lot
of twists with a description like that
the only twist we wouldn't see coming is
a straightforward narrative but of
course now you see me has plenty of
twists in store the four horsemen a
group of expert illusionists rob wealthy
benefactors and shower their audiences
with money fbi agent dylan rhodes leads
the cryptic investigation into their
crimes believing them to be members of a
secret society of magicians known as the
eye it's certainly a unique idea and the
a-list cast is an excellent selling
point unfortunately the movie eventually
starts to sag under the weight of all
the fake outs improbable escapes and
double crosses but none of them are
nearly as ludicrous as the final reveal
welcome to the eye
yes rhodes the fbi agent hunting down
the four horsemen is not only a magician
himself but the son of another legendary
illusionist and the mysterious
mastermind behind the crew's latest epic
heist farfetch doesn't begin to describe
this laughable development
like many other movies on this list
orphan has a promising start after their
child is stillborn kate and john coleman
decide to adopt a precocious
nine-year-old girl named esther
the thing is esther is far from a normal
kid
some problematic behavior might be
expected of any child who's waiting for
a home in the foster care system but
esther is a different kind of troubled
she interrupts the colemans during
intimate moments and reveals an alarming
level of knowledge about sexual topics
she scares the coleman's other children
by killing animals in front of them
sister abigail who runs the orphanage
esther was adopted from later informs
kate and john that tragedy always seems
to follow esther around
thanks sister that would have been nice
to know from the beginning at least she
let them know before esther was able to
kill her kate is quickly convinced that
esther is sinister but it takes jon
longer to accept the malevolence behind
their new daughter's behavior jon
finally admits that something is off
when esther tries to seduce him but it's
pretty much too late at that point
that's when we learn that esther isn't
nine at all and that she isn't esther
either she's a 33 year old estonian
woman with a hormone disorder the
bizarre reveal certainly explains a lot
but that doesn't make it any less
ridiculous christmas movies don't
usually wow critics and are often little
more than heartwarming distractions for
everyone else but a christmas movie that
takes its premise from song lyrics now
that's a recipe for narrative disaster
enter last christmas this story follows
kate an aspiring singer who lives with
her parents after losing her job and
getting thrown out of her lover's house
by his partner the one bright spot in
her life is tom a mysterious man with
whom she develops an intimate romance
after the two connect she reveals she
had a heart transplant a year earlier
one day kate visits tom's apartment and
discovers it's being sold she then
learns that the last owner died in a
bicycle accident the previous christmas
kate then puts two and two together and
realizes tom is the previous owner and
when he died she received his heart so
he was a ghost all along great after
learning this kate tries to focus on
doing good for others as tom would have
wanted she spends more time outside and
sings a certain wham song at a homeless
shelter while reminiscing about the good
times she had with her boyfriend whom
she never actually met what were the
lyrics again last christmas i gave you
my heart get it yeah we do too
john cuzak leads an excellent ensemble
cast and identity a slasher who done it
very loosely based on agatha christie's
and then there were none the film
follows 10 strangers stranded in a hotel
who are mysteriously killed off one by
one as the story progresses viewers are
shown flashbacks depicting important
events that supposedly occurred shortly
before the guests arrived the big twist
none of this actually happened malcolm
rivers is a condemned serial killer due
to die in less than two days his lawyers
try to stay the execution leading to an
11th hour trial in which it's revealed
that rivers has dissociative identity
disorder the hotel guest killings
represent rivers killing his different
personalities twists that are integral
to the plot like the one in identity
always work better than twists slapped
on at the last minute to shock audiences
and elevate a lousy boring story this
one is certainly thought-provoking but
ultimately too absurd and far-fetched to
stick the landing
remember me as a sweet but ultimately
forgettable rom-com for most of its run
time tyler hawkins works at the nyu
bookstore
and audits classes there while ali is a
student one night tyler and his roommate
aiden are arrested by an nypd detective
named neil after getting involved in a
fight that someone else started when
aiden discovers neil as ally's father he
convinces tyler to seduce and then dump
her to get revenge instead tyler and
ally predictably fall in love for real
after bonding over their shared trauma
and daddy issues it turns out tyler's
brother had taken his own life years
earlier leading his father to focus on
raising his sister who struggles
socially and needs support meanwhile ali
reveals her mother was mugged and
murdered when she was younger by this
point some viewers might be rolling
their eyes at all the cheap emotional
manipulation which uses extreme tragedy
as a stand-in for more subtle character
development but that's nothing compared
to what's coming next after all of these
plot threads have been resolved tyler
looks out the window of his new office
located in the north tower of the world
trade center on the morning of september
11 2001 it doesn't get more clumsily
manipulative than that
not unlike the star wars prequel trilogy
the sequels had a rocky time and divided
fans the force awakens was a welcome
return to form for many but too similar
to a new hope for others the last jedi
delighted critics with loads of fresh
thought-provoking ideas but those same
risky storytelling choices left some
fans with a bad taste in their mouths
and then there's the rise of skywalker
which pleased almost no one one of
episode nine's many narrative missteps
was how it handled the long-running
question of rey's parentage the last
jedi challenged the trope that fantasy
protagonists especially in star wars
must have a noble lineage after kylo ren
tells our heroine that she's the
descendant of nobodies however the rise
of skywalker decided to retcon that
development revealing rey to be a
relative of one of the most fearsome
figures in the galaxy far far away
emperor palpatine
you're his granddaughter
you
are a palpatine
the filmmakers behind the rise of
skywalker were almost certainly trying
to recreate the iconic reveal from the
empire strikes back but they were unable
to replicate its success instead the
sequel trilogy serves as a cautionary
tale of what happens when two filmmakers
with opposing visions are forced to
share a multi-billion dollar franchise
with the release of both iron man and
the dark knight 2008 was a great year
for superhero movies unfortunately the
ending of peter berg's hancock meant
that they couldn't all be winners will
smith plays the titular hancock an
abrasive alcoholic superhuman who can't
remember his own secret identity jason
bateman plays ray embry a pr specialist
who volunteers to help hancock
revitalize his image after the hero
saves his life with that unique and
seemingly fun premise the pieces were
all there for a recommendable one-off
action-comedy superhero flag but then
the second half of the movie happens and
we find out rey's wife is also an
immortal superhuman and she's also
hancock's ex-wife it turns out that
superheroes only have powers when
they're apart and his proximity to her
made him vulnerable to an attack 80
years ago resulting in his
hospitalization and amnesia viewers
generally agreed that hancock's two
halves felt disjointed which isn't a
surprise considering that the film was
stuck in development hell for 12 years
matthew mcconaughey and anne hathaway
had perfect chemistry in interstellar so
it was a bit of a surprise that 2019's
serenity missed the mark as much as it
did the plot sounds intriguing enough at
least on paper boat captain dill baker
is asked by his ex-wife karen to save
her and her son patrick by murdering her
abusive husband frank she books frank
for a ride on dill's boat for a week
where it should be easy to toss him
overboard with no witnesses but dill is
forced to wrestle with his conscience
over whether or not he should go through
with it after all so what's the big
twist does karen have a hidden agenda
has frank been dead the whole time is
dill secretly grindelwald in disguise no
no and no it turns out that dill is a
playable video game character designed
by patrick only after dill completes his
in-game objective does patrick work up
the courage to kill frank in real life
in his review of the film for the new
york times critic wesley morris said of
the big reveal it's like the worst of
christopher nolan m night shyamalan and
the condolence cards section at
walgreens
check out one of her newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]